[Music]
catherine lee a successful realtor from
the philippines had just landed her
biggest client yet an ultra wealthy
super secretive man she could only
describe as big this new client is a
gold mine he seems to have endless
amounts of money and no house was too
big or too expensive for him to afford
to the outside captain had just landed
every realtor's dream clients but then
out of nowhere things start going wrong
the big man accuses her of stealing from
him something she would never dream of
doing then he fires her and disappears
still confused by what happened captain
throws herself into her job a year goes
by and she completely forgets about this
mysterious big man she's far too focused
on her new foreign clients two men
looking to buy a house in manila the
capital of the philippines
on february 12 2012 the two men picked
up kathryn from her apartment in manila
and that would be the last time she's
seen alive the next day catherine's body
is found dead the cause of death
gunshots below both of her eyes
i learned that kathy was founded down
over
the piles of garbage
[Music]
the filipino police forces called in but
they just reached dead end after dead
end catherine wasn't robbed she wasn't
assaulted and the two men who were with
her had disappeared into thin air the
only thing the detective in charge was
sure of is that there's something much
bigger going on here than just a random
murder little do the authorities know
where catherine's murder would lead them
her death would help the dea uncover a
vast secret empire of a mastermind
criminal but this was no ordinary evil
genius
known only as the fat man he disrupted
the criminal underworld he was the
netflix to blockbuster the spotify to
tower records
he utilized the gig economy encrypted
mobile devices cloud sharing and novel
money laundering techniques to traffic
drugs assassinate people using his own
team of former special forces soldiers
sell arms to north korea iran somali
pirates the chinese triads people who
were plotting coups it was an innovative
criminal empire worth billions of
dollars all ran from his manila
penthouse
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime with my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
starting right now we're picking a
random instagram follower every single
week to win you just have to be
following me at jaketren just got this
new handle and you're automatically
entered watch out for fake accounts i
will never message you asking for money
and this is the story of paul leroux the
steve jobs of international organized
crime
[Music]
larue would have killed anyone who owed
him money but your credit card company
thankfully no
but that doesn't mean drowning in credit
card and high interest debt still
doesn't suck it prevents you from moving
forward in life but what if there was a
different way out what if you could get
a new loan at a smarter interest rates
use that to pay off your high interest
debts so you're left with only one fixed
monthly payment with a clear pay updates
allowing you to escape this vicious
cycle of debt once and for all while
lucky for you that's where upstart comes
in upstart is a quick and simple way to
get a personal loan that you can use to
pay down your high interest debts that
only requires one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff dates it's done all
online with easy to understand payment
terms so you'll know exactly how much
you're paying and for how long 1.8
million people have already taken
advantage of upstarts and the cool thing
is that they consider other factors
other than just your credit score
upstart looks at your income employment
and other information to get you a
smarter rate for your loan your loan
offer could be anything from 1 000 to 50
and you can check your rate in minutes
without affecting your credit score if
you end up getting an upstart loan you
could have access to your funds in as
little as one business day and you can
check your rate right now without
impacting your credit score at
upstart.comtran
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application thanks to
upstart for sponsoring this video
[Music]
born on christmas eve 1972 in the
country we now know as zimbabwe paul
aru's birth mom immediately gave him up
for adoption
a young unmarried woman of british
descent she didn't want an illegitimate
child in what was a very conservative
colonial society
adopted within weeks larue lived a
sheltered life never knowing his parents
were actually related to him as larue
grew older big changes started happening
in zimbabwe the majority of native
zimbabweans started fighting back
against the colonists when larue was 12
him and his family had to flee to south
africa to escape the violence
even though he grew up in a pretty
normal family larue was anything but
normal he hated school and at 16 he was
arrested for selling pornography which
was illegal in south africa at the time
after being arrested he dropped out of
school and found a new love computers
he joined a local programming course and
finished the one-year curriculum in just
eight weeks
everyone who knew larue could agree to
one thing
you might not like him but he's
definitely a genius
not satisfied with life in south africa
there wasn't much technology there larue
moved to england when he was 18 years
old
he got a job at a cyber security firm
and for more than a decade he lived the
normal 9 to 5 life he got married
settled down and had a great job at a
tech firm
but then in 2002 he discovers that he
was adopted and suddenly a switch flips
all of those dark influences he had been
suppressing for years come bubbling to
the surface
rage and anger filled his heart and a
few months later he gets fired from his
job for stealing and selling his
colleagues code
this was the turning point for leroux he
wasn't interested in a quiet boring life
anymore he craved something more
but to do that he would have to find a
country where his actions could go a
little more unnoticed
so in 2004 paul leroux moved to the
philippines
in the philippines larue had an epiphany
according to him americans had two great
loves popping pills and online shopping
and in 2004 the internet was booming so
what if he combined america's two great
loves into one legally gray masterpiece
in 2004 a fundamental shift was
happening in the world of drug dealing
americans didn't want street drugs
anymore they wanted pharmaceuticals the
drugs big pharma promoted on tv and
that's what leroux planned to give them
and so rx limited was born
here's how it worked leroux registered
dozens of domains for websites where
americans could buy low-level
prescription drugs like viagra online he
spammed millions of email addresses with
ads for these sites when someone clicked
on the link they would find a legit
looking website that seemed to offer a
legal way to get prescriptions and drugs
delivered to their front doors
they would fill in a short questionnaire
which would then be reviewed by a
licensed doctor
that doctor would then write a
prescription for the drugs they needed
and then the customer would then call
into larue's call centers in the
philippines to provide their credit card
details for payment as soon as that went
through the prescription would be sent
to a real us pharmacy in the rx limited
network filled with actual doctors
looking to make a quick buck and the
drugs will be shipped overnight to its
buyers with fedex
the shady doctors and pharmacists would
get a commission for every prescription
they filled bending the rules just a
little every time
even though it wasn't exactly a crime it
definitely wasn't 100 legal but larue
didn't care
he was making life-changing money
in its first four years rx limited made
300 million dollars
to give you some context most real
startups in silicon valley today are
losing money they're not even making
money and this guy's operation was
making hundreds of millions of dollars
at one point the company was fedex's
biggest customer larue became so wealthy
that he had shoe boxes of cash lining
his penthouse walls when i think about
polaroo
i think about a brilliant
arrogant
self-important self-sure very odd
individual
he's obviously a narcissist he might be
a psychopath
he bought these luxury condos at the top
of buildings he had several of them they
were unfurnished he didn't care about
furniture he didn't care about art
he didn't care about food he ate
dominoes he ate mcdonald's but he kept
two cooks there 24 7.
he never went out he didn't go to clubs
he didn't drink
but unlike another online criminal we
have covered on this channel larue kept
a low profile no one really knew who he
was and that's exactly how he liked it
but in every manila underground
marketplace there would be whispers of
the fat man the newest cartel boss on
the block
but larue was far from done yet
rx limited was just a little too legal
for him
he needed something even more exciting
[Music]
the success of the online operation
brought a problem familiar to all
illegal drug dealers what to do with all
that cash
next up larue got into the gold trade in
hong kong where he used ex-israeli
soldiers to buy up gold bars and hide
them in safe houses around the city but
those soldiers also got him thinking
about another problem safety
if he was gonna grow his business he was
gonna have to step on some toes and if
he stepped on toes he would need
protection
so larue started recruiting washed out
ex-u.s and european soldiers living in
the philippines and his very first
recruit
a guy named david smith the most generic
name you could ever have who was a
former security contractor in iraq
david became larue's point man his
mercenary who did all his dirty work for
him and with someone else to go out and
take the risks larue finally felt
comfortable starting his next business
venture
this time it was weapon smuggling
one quiet day in the philippines a ship
three hours from manila is flagged for
carrying suspicious cargo police find
dozens of boxes filled with illegal guns
the guns were made by a well-known
indonesian arms manufacturer and
according to some of the crew on board
were supposed to go to islamic militants
and rebels in the south
but that wasn't all
apparently the night before a guy
matching david smith's description had
already been on board and removed some
of those boxes and the ship's captain he
had disappeared
at first it seemed like the captain had
fled before the cops got on board but a
few days later the captain contacts a
local journalist with a crazy story to
tell
turns out the guns had been inspected
and approved for shipping by the
indonesian police the captain had
thought he was carrying legal cargo
meaning that larue had the indonesian
police on his payroll to prove his
innocence the captain said he was
willing to go public with larue's
identity if the cops put him and his
family in witness protection but the
deal never went through
about a year later while driving from
the mall with his wife and kids the
captain was pulled over by two
motorbikes and shot in the head
it was a classic filipino contract
killing and it had larue written all
over it but the killing didn't end there
you see larue had also discovered david
smith his mercenary was stealing from
him so he calls david to meet him
outside manila he asks him to dig a hole
for them to bury a safe field with money
once the hole is deep enough larue
shoots david through the head
larue's transformation was complete he
wasn't just a small time criminal trying
to bypass a few laws he was running a
full-blown international crime syndicate
and his next target iran
between 2008 and 2010 larue sent his
mercenaries to iran to discuss buying
some of their guns and weapons
the iranians were happy for the cash but
they also wanted something in return
components for their more serious
weapons
but they said we want something from you
the iranians always want something back
why not they're under incredible
sanctions and they need components from
the outside so they gave him a pretty
long shopping list he looked at it and
he said well some of this stuff i can
get and some of it is too complicated
i'm looking at
parts for weapon systems you really
can't make you can't maintain them you
can't steal all the stuff these are
highly classified systems why don't i
try to make you something that would
serve your purposes and it would be
inexpensive and it would be something
that you could reproduce from ieds to
guided missiles he had the expertise to
help them take their military to the
next level
and for the pleasure he was paid five
million dollars in gold bars
now with his iranian connections
supplying him with all the guns and
missiles he could want he started
looking for ways to innovate
[Music]
larue's profile is really interesting
because he starts off by exploiting this
space which is kind of like gray area
where what he's doing is
wrong but really not criminal
but the interesting thing about larue is
that even though he makes a lot of money
he still wants more not just from the
business that he's into but is a risk
taker who wants to do more stuff his
next plan was to set up a base in
somalia where he could build a port and
an airstrip store his weapons and easily
ship them to his customers
to do that he had to make friends with
the somali pirates who controlled the
part of somalia he was interested in he
buys them off and the game was on
he was planning to build the amazon of
arms a place where any nation gang or
militant group could buy all the weapons
they wanted but to do that he would need
someone he could trust on the ground and
that's where jack came in jack not his
real name by the way was an ex-european
soldier who had everything larue was
looking for guts a master of violence
and brains
he would call him his golden boy little
did larue know this same golden boy
would end up bringing his entire empire
down
[Music]
huh
jack quickly showed his worth in somalia
making deals with local rebel groups to
protect larue's bases in exchange for
weapons and cash
but there was a problem you see after
executing his last two associates larue
had become extremely paranoid he was
constantly worried someone was going to
stab him in the back and over the months
for no real reason he started thinking
jack was stealing from him too
so he sent his second in command a guy
named joseph hunter to take care of his
problem
only this time his target was a little
too smart and got wind of the plan
immediately jack ran for his life only
stopping to leave information about
larue on a cia tip line a tip that
wouldn't get any attention for the next
16 months
[Music]
with his empire expanding his golden boy
gone and more and more people starting
to ask questions about this mysterious
fat man larue gets even more paranoid
for the next 16 months after jack's
disappearance he tries to carry on as
normal buying up houses and expanding
his empire but then larue had catherine
lee executed the real estate agent that
we talked about at the beginning of the
video he has the filipino police and
government officials in his pocket so in
manila he's untouchable but what he
doesn't realize is that his deals in
somalia have made their way into a u.n
report on somali pirates somalia have
become a refuge for a variety of
criminal and terrorist gangs
including the islamist extremist group
al-shabaab
in 2011 reports emerged suggesting that
al-shabab was trying to build alliances
with pirates hijacking ships off the
coast
[Music]
a united nations investigation in
somalia uncovered the name of one
criminal running a massive new arms
business
this report was going to bring the big
boss onto the radar of the us
authorities
they have no idea who this larue guy is
but around the same time the cia finally
finds and passes on the tip about larue
left by his former golden boy jack
a dea agent calls the number jack left
16 months ago surprisingly he picks up
and is willing to cooperate jack knows
almost everything about larue's criminal
empire he felt completely safe his
computer system was completely encrypted
by him the only way
you would have gotten him there would
have been no email wiretaps or anything
like that you couldn't have broken into
it but if you had somebody on the inside
that's where you had it and that's where
we had we had jack he didn't know we had
jack that was all the difference
[Music]
no matter how much evidence the dea had
against larue there was no way they
could catch him in the philippines as an
american law enforcement agency the dea
would have to work with the country
larue was in to arrest and extradite him
but with almost every police officer in
manila on leroux's payroll there was no
way he wouldn't get tipped off about the
dea's plans to catch larue they were
going to have to lure him out
this was the dea's golden opportunity if
jack could get larue to leave the
philippines to admit to committing a
crime they could finally get their guy
so they planned a risky sting jack would
go back to work and mention to larue
that he had made new contacts in
colombia he would say the colombians who
were actually dea agents are looking to
bypass the mexicans and buy their own
meth
jack knows that larue has been buying
meth from north korea so he would
definitely be interested the next step
would be to arrange a meeting with the
colombians in a third party country that
was friendly with the dea
that's where they would make the arrest
luckily for jack and the dea everything
went exactly as planned larue was so
excited by the idea of supplying meth to
the colombians that he did something he
never did before he left manila
the colombians had requested he meet
them in liberia a country in northwest
africa liberia's chief of national
security had worked with the dea plenty
of times before and they knew they could
count on his support
larue arrives in liberia he arranges a
meeting with jack at a local hotel
little does he know jack is recording
every word of their conversation
let's wait for the prices
and it couldn't be better for the dea
jack and larue are supposed to meet
again later that day this time the
meeting takes place in larue's hotel
room minutes after jack arrives the dea
agents and two liberian cops knock on
the hotel door what happens next is a
blur but in the end larue ends up in the
custody of dea agents on a plane headed
to the u.s but it's not over yet because
larue still had one trick left up his
sleeve
so now at this time we've been up i
don't know 72 hours
we just wanted to kind of go to sleep
and he goes
okay let's talk
and then the game is on again
the first thing he says to us is
well-played gentlemen
well played
suddenly he's offering them bigger fish
in exchange for a deal he's telling them
about his deals with iran and north
korea and as much as the dea doesn't
want to they have to listen the
information larue shares gives them a
completely new view of how these
countries bypass sanctions as much as
they hate it larue is valuable so they
start negotiating a deal no one knows
larue has been arrested if they could
get him to run his organization from
jail america has the chance to gather
priceless intelligence and capture his
entire team and that's exactly what they
do
for months after his arrest larue keeps
everything going as usual and the u.s
scoops up all the key members of larue's
cartel and even after demanding immunity
for his crimes besides drug trafficking
larue eventually pleads guilty to
everything
and on june 12th 2020 nearly eight years
after his arrest larue is sentenced to
25 years in jail
when he gets out he'll be deported back
to the philippines where he will stand
trial for all the murders he committed
in the country plus his arms smuggling
without the money to bribe any more
filipino cops and officials larue is
probably going to spend the rest of his
life in prison
hope you guys enjoyed the video this was
a super fascinating story that actually
a viewer submitted so shout out to him
if you're new here my name is jake and
we make documentaries just like this one
every single week for free on money
power and crime multiple times a week so
if you like that click that subscribe
button below remember you can always
dislike and unsubscribe whenever you
want so you might as well do it stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
you